so uh we took that 3d model that sam and
downloaded and augmented as you can see
here it's like it's got these weird
fracture points like you can like break
this it's actually already broken and we
also have the gopro session you put it
right here in the middle the issue is
that this is so low down that it's like
all the gopros are all going to be in
the in the shot just modeled a quick
little
thing here basically put the little
gopro here in that
and this will sit in the rig here it's
weird that there aren't really any
dimensions for the session online but i
just i literally just wanted to know how
thick it was how long it was how wide it
was
i measured it myself it is not 35
millimeters it is 38 millimeters
hey jake oh hey
all right so
what do you need to make a metagross
solid bionic arm well first things first
you need an under layer one left-handed
black glove one
left sleeve of a black shirt crafting
foam you can buy this online but it's
basically like yoga foam outside of a
clorox uh
disinfecting wipes can you know
materials should come cheap heat gun
used with adult supervision or
you know what to do is it latex paint
see what happens it's just like
kindergarten you know i was telling ren
earlier
wren might be the engineer who became a
vfx artist and creator
and i'm the lawyer who became a prop
maker and that's all you need you start
from there sent this over to spencer
over in stress level zero to print it on
their 3d printer so let's go check out
if it uh turned out well
wait do you have records to play on it
i got like one that's enough yep
that's the guy i was wanting to see
you're looking for me do you know if the
print turned out well yes it did yes
let's go check it out
[Music]
there it is makerbot replicator2x
shy all right
moment of truth
it is okay i don't want to break it
so
hopefully this will fit
it does
a little tighter next time maybe now for
the second moment of truth if you don't
mind holding this i brought the session
[Music]
no
we reprinted this piece one percent
bigger it finally fits now and it's way
tighter in the hole it goes all the way
down so it's like we have all the angles
hanging outwards the only piece you're
missing from a rig like this is
literally just the bottom patch in
effect you can literally go in and like
throw a tile down at the bottom now this
rig is entirely finished in fact we
could probably actually use this for the
final thing oh it still it wiggles a bit
but i mean it's not going to be moving
so it's not a big deal
amazon our favorite retailer wait are
these the wheelchairs or these dumb
chairs these are the the same trees that
we all are getting those ones yeah oh
well i got a special trick for myself so
we're gonna have three nice chairs
anymore
i mean nick that's not run get
down oh what
bouncing
okay
do you give me the arnold schwarzenegger
quote one more time
yeah just chopper off of me
take that out
what up i did it
i screw that wall
i hate you guys
oh i love knives